bonjour vous raillez bienvenue sûreté
gonal tv spéciale championnat du monde
alan topalov parti numéro 10 là
exceptionnellement sur des modèles tv
aujourd'hui je n'ai pas d'invité pour
cette partie ça nous empêchera pas de la
regarder évidemment détails alors à ce
moment du match
évidemment il ya égalité entre les
joueurs à nantes s'est fait rejoindre au
score
la partie va être très intéressante
puisqu'on va revoir une variante que
topaloff avait joué dans la partie
numéro un la fameuse défense
grunfeld alors ce match a été très
intéressant de ce côté là puisque
topalov avec les blancs avait aussi
essayé une autre défense la défense
slave trois fois de suite
anand avait dû tenter trois variantes
différentes afin d'éviter les
préparations de topalov il est fini par
chuter dans la troisième c'est pour ça
qu'on attendait un an d'un peu au
tournant lors de cette partie est ce
qu'il allait rejouer la défense lavaud
risque ben de reperdre encore une fois
ou revenir éventuellement à la grünfeld
de la première partie où il avait aussi
perdu mais ce qui se passe et c'est
intéressant de le noter dans ces matches
là c'est qu'évidemment les joueurs ne
viennent pas seuls ils viennent avec des
seconds ans avec des gens qui viennent
pour les aider à préparer évidemment
leur ouverture et éventuellement
améliorer les parties au fil du match
donc entre la première partie et 7/10
parti al andar abandonné la green fee
lille a joué la slave donc comme on l'a
vu avec le résultat de finalement un peu
mitigé deux nuls une perte est là
en fait entre temps les seconds en ont
dû ont pu améliorer la défense d'un an
sur la green fed et lui proposer autre
chose et donc là anne andreu surprend
topalov en revenant sur cette ouverture
et profite de l'effet de surprise dans
tout cas va essayer de profiter les
futures prises pour éviter la défaite et
pourquoi pas l'emporter même si une
victoire avec les noirs est extrêmement
rare en championnat du monde
eh bien on y va on va voir cette partie
topalov contre allende numéro 10 topalov
à les blancs et démarre donc cette
partie avec le coût standard des quatre
donc ou de la dame habituel ensuite donc
la hollande répond par cabaye m6 on le
voit ces quatre g6 caractéristiques ici
d'une défense indienne alors c'est soit
une grünfeld comme on le voit dans la
partie soit mais quand le fou se
développe en jet set avant que les noirs
de joux dessin qui ne joue pas des cinq
dans ce cas là ça serait une estonienne
mais depuis depuis les années 80 et les
matchs kasparov et karpov on ne voit
plus à un championnat du monde alors on
continue avec cavale et c3 pour topalov
et dessins voilà ces caractéristiques de
la grünfeld alors pour l'instant on suit
comme je l'avais indiqué en début
d'émission on suit la première partie du
match
donc on va suivre les mêmes coûts c'est
prendre des cinq cas va les prendre et
5e 4 et après cavale et prend ses trois
qui on prend cavaliers fou g7 fou c4 et
c5 on a la caractéristique de la grüne
fait vie si on suit toujours la première
partie mais je vais vous rappeler le
principe en échange du fait que les
noirs ont laissé les blancs ici dominé
le centre avec leurs pions et bien il le
contre attaque avec fuji cette très bien
placé et en jouant ses 5es mais ils
dévoilent leur plan qui est de contre
attaquer ce centre en fait ils se
servent de ce centre blandford qui
effectivement fort qui est une force du
côté blanc ils s'en servent comme cible
donc tout le débat va être là est ce que
ce centre va suffisamment de force
suffisamment longtemps pour permettre
aux blancs de d'en tirer un avantage ou
est ce que les noirs vont réussir à le
faire exploser
afin de
de gagner un avantage à dynamique et
pourquoi pas prendre l'aventage et
basculer dans une finale avantage alors
notamment un des plans aussi des noirs
aussi c'est qu'après les changes des
pions c'est aider au centre et bien ils
ont à long terme
une petite majorité ici de deux pions
contre un qui peut s'avérer décisive en
finale et faire au moins office de
contrepoids voilà les idées générales de
cette défense alors on continue
maintenant les blancs développe par
cavalier 2 alors l'idée de cavaliers de
l est assez simple à la fois je protège
la casse des quatre qui est quand même
sous le feu du pion du fou et de la
madame adverse
je rajoute un défenseur et déjà le pion
c3 qui protège et la dame donc là ça
fait 3 contre 3 donc ça tient les normes
pourrait faire qu'un échange de pions et
après ils ne peuvent plus prendre à
moins de perdre une pièce ce qui est ce
qui est tant de questions évidemment est
en jeu car aliot de si j'évite le coup
j'ai quatre évidemment ça c'est
important puisque en jouant cavalier f3
si j'avais joué ce cavalier sur la case
f3 j'aurais permis aux faux adverse
devenir angers 4 ce qui ici serait punie
parce le simple f3 ça permet aussi
évident de préparer le petit rock
donc c'est un coup souple car lieu deux
typique de la grünfeld alors les noirs
continuent leur pression centrale très
logique
dans la lignée de ce qu'on a vu avec
cavalli c6 voilà un attaquant de plus
contre le pion des 4 regardez comme
c'est extrêmement logique et on essayait
de faire sauter ce centre évidemment si
les blancs jouent par exemple coup comme
des saints qui est envisageable mais
surtout toujours envisagé ce genre de
coups mais en compensation de quoi mais
attention le pion c3 commence à être
attaquée par le fou est un peu faible
le cavalier de doit rester en défense la
case
des cartes n'est pas trop fait de mon
camion qui protège mais déjà l'on peut
pas y poster une pièce et surtout on
affaiblit la case e 5 et puis on a
bouché notre fou c4 donc ça serait
concédé au noir est la réussite de leur
plan donc les blancs et vite comme ça d'
affaiblir leur case centrale en jouant
simplement fou et 3 donc il rajoute un
défenseur à la case sur la case autre
des quatre ici donc là les noirs
continue logiquement leur partie
développement petit rock les blancs
aussi petit rock et là les noirs doivent
commencer à jouer quelque chose
de planifier de commencer à rentrer dans
les plans concrets et là dans la
première partie en inde avait joué le
câble et ses 600 à 5
c'était le coup d'un an ce fameux coup
car il ya celles qui a kiss été suivie
par une défaite donc topalov rejoue la
même chose puisque à priori que vous
avez gagné une partie sur une ouverture
vous avez envie évidemment de renouveler
donc allant de en fête devait trouver
quelque part à un moment donné un moyen
de sortir de cette première partie
évidemment et il le trouve avec ici
enfin en tout cas ils le proposent par
le coup b6 alors qui est classique un
qui est connu il versait pas ce pas une
nouveauté théorique d'un angle le combat
xi skies et solide qui simplement jette
un petit oeil sur la cassure le pion ces
5 maisons laprise qu'on l'a vu est pas
terrible pour les blancs parce que en
échange de cette prise dans ses seins
qui a l'option c3 qui devient faible le
fou g7 qui commence à jouer et les
pièces noires qui s'activent le coup b6
aussi a pour objectif de sortir le x 6
par exemple en bessette le coup b6 ne
préjuge pas de la possibilité de jouer
car il ya cinq plus tard qui reste un
coup jouable surtout quand on a joué au
foot 17 ski transfert l'activité sur le
plan des cats sur le pion aux 4 qui
serait alors attaqué par le foot c'est
aussi dans l'idée de b6 d'avoir une case
de sauvegarde pour lecavalier 9 cases
sur en plus puisqu'il ya plus de pions
sur la colline b pour attaquer ce
cavalier donc dam des deux de topalov
coût 30 il est logique on lit les tours
donc ça c'est classique aux échecs aussi
une fois qu'on a rauque et si on peut
lier les tours c'est bien ça permet au
tour de venir au centre
ces deux colonnes sont cruciales
peut-être même la colombe et peut être
cruciale aussi peut mettre une tour sur
la colombie est comme ça on peut mettre
les deux tours vers le centre en soit
pour protéger le pied toujours un pion
des cas sur la colonne des soit pour
anticiper des prises en déca rateront ou
un coup après une prise handicap venir
sur la colonne sait où il peut y avoir
aussi du jeu on va voir ça dépend ce que
l'on joue les noirs donc foulé cette ça
c'est logique c'est l idée du coût des
six tours assez un tranquille donc là
les blancs ici au lieu de horn ne
choisissent pas d'où ils auraient pu
tenter pourquoi pas tomber un c'était
envisagé
pourquoi pas tous des hommes pour s'y
jouer le retour en d1 est au rêve d un
avec l'idée de contrôler sur le centre
est bon mais choisir notre couteau
paloffis six tours assez inquiets très
bon bien sûr l'idée c'est pas tellement
de protéger ces trois s'est passé c'est
que tôt ou tard les noirs risque de
prendre des 4 et donc c'est de libérer
après cette colonne la tour est déjà
placée en cas d'ouverture au centre ça
dissuade les noirs en quelque sorte de
prendre des cadres alors les noirs font
la même chose ils mettent une tour
l'anvisa be ce qui permettra de
contrecarrer la puissance de cette tour
en cas d'ouverture ensemble tous rêvent
d un voilà les bleus ont fini leur
développement
après tout rêve d un toutes les pièces
ont joué sont sortis ce sont des cases
de quasiment optimale et pour les noirs
c'est quasiment la même chose
la seule pièce qui ne joue pas c'est la
torre fuite
pour l'instant donc on pourrait
envisager je sais pas de jouer par
exemple la dame pourquoi pas en 17
ce coup là est ce que c'est possible on
peut le regarder de seconde pourquoi pas
fou 17 avec l'idée de jouer tous rêvent
dé 8
voilà on finirait le développement ainsi
mais on se heurterait possiblement ici à
l'attack standards de la grüne funky ou
s'ils attaquent standard de l'as dragons
ou voire de la benoni c'est à dire quand
on a comme ça une structure en fuyant
qu'eto'o jours et on pourrait jouer 3 6
et changer ce fou extrêmement puissant
des noirs et pourquoi pas tenter de
monter une attaque avec les blancs par
h4h scène par exemple essayer de casser
un peu ce set cette structure alors
allende ici disent on va commencer à
s'activer et a réalisé un peu le plan
des noirs donc il va déjà diminué la
pression enfin là la quantité de pions
centraux
notamment ceux plus étroits qui supporte
des quatre il va être obligé de bouger
il va sera menée au centre après c'est
prendre des quatre s'éprend des cartes
voilà on a simplifié un petit peu là la
densité de pion central
hélas les noirs après cet échange fond
le ku'damm d66 qui est un coût mais qui
à la fois libéral academy donc ça on l'a
vu pour la tour des huit qui voudra
éventuellement s'activer et puis aussi
qui peut pourquoi pas menacé de venir
aussi sur a3 on sait pas ça peut être
une case utile après on va essayer de
chasser ce fou ces quatre peut-être
affaiblir ceux qui ont à deux ça peut
être une idée aussi y en a trois et peut
être réactive la dame aussi pourquoi pas
en b 4 des 6 elle protège aussi en d6
évidemment la case de 5 qui peut être
une idée de jouer aux 5 si l'occasion se
présente donc là les blancs plusieurs
couleurs possibles
alors alors à leur disposition on nous
aurait pu tenter eux seck qui est
intéressant ici par exemple 5 évidemment
j'attaque la dame je bouge un peu
l'activité du fou 17 en échange de quoi
j'ai faibli par contre la casse des 5 et
toute la diagonale du de cette diagonale
là donc les noirs vont essayer après de
de profiter de cette de cette faiblesse
peut être en juin dame 17 pour venir sur
les cases blanches
voyez ce genre d'idées mais ça pourrait
être une idée de jouer le 5 puis après
pourquoi pas des jouets aussi soucis
derrière mais au 5e s'affaiblit g secte
le fou g7 puisqu'il heurte un mur mais
ça libère par contre notre fou donc il
ya des pour les avantages des
inconvénients
alors là topalov choisir notre coût qui
est tout aussi bon
qui est une autre idée donc là si on
joue des 5 voilà des cinq ans le
problème de d5
c'est évidemment que ça libère le
potentiel du fou 17 mai on l'a vu
maintenant qu'on a joué tour c est
maintenant qu on a repris tout à l'heure
en c3 il n'y a plus aucune cible sur
cette diagonale
ça reste des cases de faibles évidemment
pour les blancs maintenant une fois
qu'on a joué des simples mais c'est
compensé par le fait qu'il ya pas de
cible il n'y a pas de grosses pièces
derrière n'y a pas de pression
autre qu'une pression je dirais purement
spatiale contrôle spatial un contrôle de
cases qui peut être utile mais qui n'est
pas qui n'est pas vraiment gênant tout
de suite alors cavaliers à 5 de la part
des noirs donc classique on l'a vu ce
cavalier souvent bien à 5 on l'a vu dès
le début de la partie
un an devait jouer son terme indique été
attaqués et en jouant à 5 en plus ils
forcent les blancs à trouver une
solution pour leurs fous ces quatre
kinés protéger qu'une fois par la tour
alors qu'il est attaqué deux fois par le
canada 5 et la tour s'est vite donc là
topalov shu fu bay 5-1 tranquillement
alors pourquoi pourquoi food et 5 et pas
par exemple food et 3,2 sous les 3 était
envisageable aussi voilà la réponse on
pouvait aussi je me fous des trois mais
il choisit simplement fou b5 l'un des
deux coups sont à peu près équivalents
alors évidemment les cils et noir jouent
à 6 ha les blancs sont contents d'avoir
je me fous des cinq qui vont revenir en
b3 en attendant les noirs sont affaiblis
déjà tout de suite le pion b6 serait
soul attaque du fou ou trois aînés
protéger qu'une seule fois donc c'est
des pions qui deviennent des cibles et
on voit en plus que si ce pion bouge
c'est le cavalier à saint qui serait en
prison voyage ou le problème de bouger
de bouger ses pions s est jamais simple
donc après fou b5 simplement les noirs b
et c de de limiter un peu la pression la
pression blanche elle est quand même
présente c'est sur la colonne c'est ici
bon mais il ya une petite pression les
blancs pourraient si on les laisse faire
essayer de peut être de mettre une
pression cette colonne peuvent aussi
essayé d'échanger le fou g7 par food et
4 alors anand simplifie la position
allège la pression des pièces par des
échanges
alors comme on l'a dit aussi au début le
petit avantage énorme cette ouverture
parce qu'il ya toujours une compensation
au centre fort des blancs qui reste fort
si les pions elle peut bouger la cc de
pions de pions contre 1 or 2 pions
contreur éloigné c'est toujours un
avantage mais au final donc pour arriver
à une finale il faut échanger des pièces
donc ça justifie les coups suivants la
langue pour penser un tour français un
tour s'est vite je propose un échange
généralisé déjà deux tours si les tours
s'échange approche de la finale
si les dames s'échange je serai
totalement en finale et l'a peut-être
que ses deux pions contraint peuvent
même devenir un avantage pour les noirs
et le centre est moins fort évidemment
le centre fort c'est bien pour prendre
un avantage devant milieu de jeu mais ça
devient moins moins grave en finale
alors ici topalov do as trois petits
coups tranquillement fait ils se
pressent pas topaloff simplement il joue
un petit coup toujours utile la petite
fenêtre tranquille pour éviter bon ben
ça y est toujours des mains du coup leur
possible mais pourquoi pas préparés
aussi une expansion les lois en finale
par g4 pourquoi pas c'est envisageable
ce qui empêchera délibération noir par
f5 f5 pour être une idée pour le noir
plus tard puisqu'un joueur f5 j'attaque
le pion aux 4es en cas de prise et bien
c'est le pion des 5 qui sera voyez donc
là c'est un coût qui peut préparer g4
qui peut être utile en finales pourquoi
pas pour penser un d'un procès puis
toujours la petite fenêtre imminente et
la e6 de la part des noirs alors
toujours dans l'idée générale de cette
ouverture
le coût 6 est très intéressant puisque
ont fait exploser le centre blanc
évidemment on fait sauter ici le la tête
de pont ici blanche dessin qu'on peut
pas vraiment défendre avec les blancs
facile on peut la défendre mais c'est
pas facile à défendre puisque on va
attaquer avec le pion aux six attaques
et le pion 17 et la dame et ses protégés
que par le pion donc c'est un peu faible
mais il ya une défense dynamique
heureusement je dis est ce qu'en dit
tenir pour les
pour les blancs la défense passive
aurait été de prendre 1 6 mais en ce cas
là on concède le centre on n'a plus
vraiment davantage au centre on n'a plus
qu'un seul pion fait d'en prendre six le
pion aux quatre restent sous pression et
on est obligé de jouer des coups passif
contre détroit des choses comme ça donc
eu six cavaliers f4 voilà donc ça c'est
un coup dynamique alors c'est
intéressant comme il ya quatre puisque
on protège évidemment dessin et surtout
et puis on commence à faire pression sur
aussi son menace clairement puis on
prend 1,6 obligeant les noirs à
reprendre du pied au f avec une
faiblesse le pion aussi sera faible
puisqu'il sera isolé non protégés par
d'autres pions donc attaquable donc fera
office de cible
donc il faut éviter ça donc là on en
prend des cinq tout simplement et aprica
va les prendre et sec et on se dit mais
ça a l'air bon pour le nord qui gagne un
pion puisqu'après faut prendre cavaliers
on se dit qu'après pions prend fou il y
aurait dans prendre et on a gagné un
pion sauf que ici alors c'est quand il
faut quand même le noter c'est qu'après
après f
après pardon après il faut prendre des 5
peut prendre ici les blancs jouent en
fait dame début simplement en clouant le
fou et donc on reprendra en d5 avec le
pion très certainement pour garder les
dom sur l'échiquier et avoir un pion
passé fort au centre avec une paire de
fou voilà donc ça c'est le problème
aussi c'est que ça donne la paire de
fouet mais ça et en plus ça gagne
papillon dames d2 simplement et on ne
perd pas de pions il faut toujours se
méfier dans ce genre de situation la
prise immédiate peut se voir opposer un
coup
datant tous enfin tout quoi un coup
intermédiaire voilà donc on pensait plus
en cour intermédiaire dam des deux qui
permet de ne pas perdre le pion et de
ressortir avec un avantage certain
au lieu de quoi on joue le plus subtil
et plus efficace plus fort tout
simplement aussi f5 très intéressante
puisque fc attaque label la défense du
cavalier le pion aux quatre donc évident
si les blancs prennent évidemment c'est
le local et qu'il soit donc c'est hors
de question donc gros problème pour les
blancs ça fait quand même beaucoup de
choses en prison maintenant le cavalier
qui est quand même sous la pression du
fou de la dame
et puis alors après f5 d'un angle le
pion mais dynamiquement ils sont
toujours mieux les blancs s'ils arrivent
à se sortir de ce guêpier puisque c'est
quand même un vrai souci cette position
puisque ils ont toujours un avantage au
centre un cavani central des cinq un
pion central car pour l'instant
voilà donc la taupe à l'homme joue le
simple et sans doute connu de lui c'est
sans doute tout ceci procède d'une
analyse précise f3 voilà l trois coups
suffisant pour simplement protégé e 4
alors après f34 f34 avait quand même on
a juste un petit souci avec les blancs
auquel il faut faire attention donc il
faut quand même être précis c'est qu'on
a un pion aux 4 qui quand même isolé
mais qui quand même passé voilà c'est à
dire que c'est à la fois possiblement
une faiblesse mais aussi une force
l'appui on passait donc qui peut aller à
dame dans une position qui pas en plus
ce tout à fait une finale donc les noirs
sont obligés de jeter un oeil au centre
on sait que les pièces soient semblant
talence cavaliers il est magnifique
puisqu'il est il est bien placé contrôle
des cases beaucoup de cases en camp
adverse ils bouchent l'année gonelle du
fou donc la pression dynamique est du
côté du côté blanc alors à noter par
ailleurs le type de piège qui peut
arriver dans cette position qu'elle il
faut faire attention si vous jouez ça on
peut se dire par exemple pour garder
type de piège bon c'est juste je donne à
titre indicatif
mais qui est vraiment intéressant si on
joue cavalier à six car il ya six salles
et l'idée pour les noirs intéressant on
se dit puisque carla si je vais venir à
1,5 et moi aussi j'ai un bon cavalier
sur une case centrale et je contrôle de
belles cases dans le nord
sauf que rare 10 ou simplement c'est
réfuté cette idée par fou prend
cavaliers et surtout prendre fou regarde
et je sacrifie la dame puisqu'après d'un
programme simplement regarder magnifique
fourchette ici ce qu'on appelle la
fourchette royal roi dame et je récupère
la dame avec une pièce de plus piège
classique mais à connaître donc on se
devait quand même de le citer dans cette
position après cavaliers c6 donc après
elle prend un 4s prend le cas ici les
noirs jouent dames 5
voilà donc vous voyez on peut pas
ramener le cavalier soins qu'à deuxième
mais on y met la dame alors très
intéressant school au gîte aussi en
jouant dame cinq jeux menace maintenant
faut prendre puisqu'il n'y a plus le
clouage vous rappelez vous la d'amendé
si si je mettais d'amendé 2 il ya
clouage là je menace vous prend et on
peut pas jouer dam des deux
simplement on aurait perdu une pièce
donc leur place de gagner un pion et en
plus cette dame 1,5
le bloc le pion aux 4 qui peut pas
avancer et puis elle se met en batterie
ce qu'on appelle une batterie avec le
fou g7 et elle compterait un contrôle
très très bien tout c'est la diagonale
noir évidemment
alors il faut absolument dans cette
position que topalov on joue des coûts
extrêmement précis pour éviter de se
retrouver en infériorité ici taupe à la
joue et trouve le coup intéressant fou
des trois sous detroit alors ça c'est
évidemment un bon coup je vais pas dire
que c'est un mauvais coup c'est clair
c'est un bon coup mais qui lâche le pion
desseigne toutefois évident ça protège
le pion cas parce que la menace aussi
d'un lynx et de prendre le pion 4 1 la
menace immédiate des trois toutefois
après ici fou prend des scènes qui
auraient pu être joué par un angle
puisqu'on a dû alors il ya encore moins
d'âme des deux puisque maintenant il ya
le foot en dessin simplement les blancs
auraient repris en d5 et après d'en
prendre et 5 sinon ben là les blancs la
paire de fous plus influents pas c'est
fort ça sera un gros avantage il faut
absolument justifié la prise du cavalier
par la prise du pion et là il ya des
problèmes après dame s'est vite tout
simplement
même si huit échecs et le roi est
quasiment obligé de venir avec sept ou
alors on peut jouer le faux et fuite
mais dans ce cas là c'est le fou qui
devient passif voilà est par exemple un
coup comme fou h6 menace d'un point en
huit matches et donc ça obligerait à
faire des coups quand même une sorte
cité joie quand même dame c5 comme ça
échecs dames ces cinq échecs est sûre
c'était quand même jouable
évidemment avec intéressant pour les
noirs en est sûr il aurait pu jouer ça
un nom bien sûr après pions prendre
comprendre quand même un pion pour pour
la paire de fouet si on vient de jouer
il faut sans doute revenir avec le fou
et on a un pion net de moins alors qu'a
prévu
topalov là dessus
je suis patient qu'il est prévu dans
chose lors d'autres and on n'a pas voulu
jouer ce coup qui était quand même tout
à fait envisageable ici donc ça c'est la
cité de faire [ __ ] en dessin au lieu
de quoi il fait alors le coup qu'on
avait cité tout à l'heure qui est
maintenant possible cavale et c6 appelé
voûte à leur arrivée le fond en bessin
qu'on pouvait prendre dans ses six même
prendre avec l'adav puisqu'à la fin y
avait une fourchette 3 pièces à la fin
sur cette case mais ici c'est même plus
le cas il ya plus fous il n'y a plus
rien donc qu'elle sait si ce et l'aura
donc voilà donc j'ai mis la dame en 1 5
et 1 a dû trouver que ça devait être
mieux pour lui et il n'a pas vu un coût
allant ici dans cette position hélas ce
cavalier
en fait il était sinon c'est intéressant
comme il est et puisque le cavalier
menace de venir en d4 avec là aussi une
pièce centralisée donc là il faut
revenir sur cette idée karaté un an phu
prend dessins que prendrait cette dame
prend des 5 et est ce que les blancs en
coups et bien non il n'y a pas de coupes
claires dans cette position donc là on a
cru prendre un avantage peut-être plus
positionner les gens car ici mais il a
oublié un coup dans cette position fort
pour les blancs pas facile à trouver
assez assez même curieux si on peu de
joueurs le retrouver je pense quand même
topalov vous le magnifique fois ci sur
certaines précisions d'un homme qui a
laissé six au lieu de donner la paire de
fou comme trompions en d5 avec une
finale finalement légèrement avantageuse
pour les noirs quoique la paire de fou
doivent réussir à faire un équilibre
faut à 6 alors là problème pourquoi
bella il s'en sort un peu les blancs
parce qu'on va voir la suite
si les noirs avaient pris en a six mais
simplement d'un procès 6 et ans
on a une bonne position avec les blancs
puisque on a un cas valais central fort
on a des menaces de faire dame 1,8 échec
pour prendre pourquoi pas le pion à 7
derrière on a aussi des pièges alors bon
c'est bien au total à nos réponses repas
tomber un piège après mais après d'en
prendre quatre comme il faut noter que
des coups comme simplement comme
cavalier six échecs haut rhin il faut
parer les chèques par exemple par franck
cavallier mais mais mais évidemment ça
permet de gagner la dame noire donc
évidemment c'est pas possible donc on
voit la force du cavalier donc son fou à
6 ben non d un peu déstabilisé et il
joue l'intermédiaire qu'à valider 4 et
c'est sans doute là que maintenant on
n'a pas vu le coup suivant puisque
qu'avec des 4 semble fort puisque le fou
à 6 maintenant et emprise du foot 17
mais pas si les blancs prennent le
fourbe et 7
il y à cavalia 2 maintenant ce sont les
noirs pour garder le même thème qui font
une fourchette
radâmes donc ici sur x 6 à nantes joue
qu'avec des cadres donc on est noir et
il n'a pas vu sans doute la réponse de
topalov qui suffisante et qui permet
finalement de garder un petit avantage
pour les blancs montage dynamique
toujours avec le centre toujours cette
histoire de centre dame c4 voilà
mesdames ces quatre gros problème alors
il en je protège le pouce et quatre jeux
contrôler la case au delà il y avait
cette histoire de cavaliers façon j'ai
sorti la dame de sang il y avait des
problèmes et bâle et noir peuvent
toujours pas à jouer des coups comme
d'en prendre quatre tout simplement
puisque
ici un simple coup comme cavalier f6 m6
échec double échec de la dame et échecs
du cavalier extrêmement pénible puisque
après roy f8 on peut faire d'alger vite
échec et a pris un set on prend le fou
avec échec et on continue les manoeuvres
des chèques sans doute avant de et puis
on prend la dame à la fin surtout ça
fait beaucoup quand même
évidemment donc c'est pas possible donc
sur dame c4 on voit la menace
ce double échec qui est une menace
énorme et donc là un hand est obligé de
faire [ __ ] en essais mais c'est moins
intéressante alors évidemment ça c'est
clair puisque on va pas gagner le pion
alors c'est là que la nand a raté
quelque chose dans cette danse est parti
sans doute au moins une finale facile à
jouer ou non de quoi il va se retrouver
en difficulté puisque après d'emprunter
5 d'emprunter 5 d'un an et peut prendre
des saints la veille ce sont les blancs
qui ont un léger avantage alors dû à
quoi
un pion passé donc qui peut s'avérer
faible mais qui en l'occurrence n'est
pas faible parce que les blancs dont la
paire de fou et la paire de foudre cette
position permet de contrôler à distance
à la fois les cases blanches qu'on le
voit ici avec le fou de cases blanches
et les cases noires regarder comme ça se
complètent bien ici évidemment les cases
rouges et les casques blancs et les
cases noires et les cases blanches pour
les blancs ça fait beaucoup de potentiel
en échange de quoi le cavalier des
quatre est moins puissant qu'un fou donc
c'est une finale pas facile à jouer pour
les noirs alors annonce va quand même
extrêmement bien manoeuvré dans cette
finale où il est quand même un tout
petit peu moins bien on va voir la suite
alors les noirs ou des coûts de
centralisation fouet 5 on centralise les
rois alors ça c'est classique
maintenant regardez lors on a bien de
jouer là et pareil on en ramène son
revers le centre donc ça c'est un
système qui fonctionne en connaître et
que vous devez mettre en oeuvre quand
vous faites des parties
quand vous arrivez au final n'oubliez
pas qu'à ce moment là le roi n'est plus
vraiment sous la menace
de maths ça peut arriver mais c'est
beaucoup plus rare et cesson et position
en général assez précise donc en général
le roi devient une pièce active donc il
faut absolument mettre en jeu donc
toujours anticiper cette finale est une
fois donc les pièces cours d'échangés
penser au roi confiait s'activent très
important si vous jouez avec vos pièces
et l'adversaire avec ses pièces en
nombre équivalent évidemment et sont
loin mais vous êtes en infériorité
dynamique là où le jeu se passe donc
n'oubliez pas d'activer votre roi fou g5
alors issifou g5 l'idée c'est de
regarder le roi regardez comme c'est
malin souffre ou g5 puisqu'il fait qu'il
complète avec le pion des scènes qui
contrôle la classe de 6 et le fond lui
contrôle on regardait les cases noires
donc ce qui fait que le roi noir ne peut
pas bouger donc il est mis dans une
petite boîte grâce à ce petit coup un
petit coup mal un fou g5y en retardent
l'arrivée du roi on semble pas ce que
seront elles auraient aimé venir en
recettes voire en d6 et faire pression
sur ce pion évident
donc là il est pour l'instant éloigné du
pian et donc de l'action puisque
l'action se déroule à et les bleus vont
essayer d'amener leurs droits au centre
et de commencer à déstabiliser les noirs
voyez la puissance des fournisseurs et
la complémentarité ici on voit une
complémentarité forte entre pion est fou
mais c'est la même complémentarité qu'on
verra entre le foot cases blanches et le
fou de cases noires vous voyez la force
de ces fouilles cavaliers f5 donc à
l'aan d'alors joue classique ici le
cavalier en gênant est un excellent
bloqueur donc en mettant le cavaliere
des six on va le voir puisque après g4
regarder rappelait tout à l'heure je
vous avais parlé d' h3g 4 ça y est le
jouet topaloff
ils viennent jouer g4 les noirs jouent
calais des 6 et là on note une autre un
autre thème fondamental dans les finales
que vous devez connaître aussi qui est
la complémentarité du fou et du cavalier
ont regardé le cavalier noir ici il
alors à la fois ils bloquent le pion des
5 pouces assez mal puisque ce cavalier
ne permet pas aux pions d'avancé comme
en plus c'est une pièce à courte portée
le cavalier c'est souvent une excellente
classe pour lui de se mettre comme ça
devant un pion et ça n'empêche pas de
contrôle et regarder les cases blanches
donc il fait office de complément à son
fou de couleurs opposées
regardez comme les deux contrôles des
cases complémentaire donc ça crée une
petite barrière ici qui empêche le roi
blanc doit venir au centre donc on a
deux petits fort opposé un petit fort de
la part des blancs qui bloque le roi
noir et un petit fort ici on est ravi de
la part des noirs qui bloque le roi
blanc ça n'empêche pas les blancs de
centraliser un peu plus le revoir f3 et
là les noirs jouent beaucoup d'attentes
en fait ici me 1,8 c'est quasiment un
coup d'attentats lors il est quand même
curieux ce qu'il ya huit puisque ce cas
les huit on aurait pu tenter avec les
blancs ici le simple 3e 4 sur quoi en
fait les noirs très certainement aurait
joué un coup qu'on me fous j'ai trois
ouvrages 2 suivi de calais des six
échecs
c'est le genre de chose qui aurait
permis au roi noir devenir un des quatre
mais on aurait pu continuer à harceler
le roi avec le fou imaginons ici après x
h 2 par exemple un coup comme fou b5 et
après
cabaye échec ouah ah ben on en parle
c'est pas possible puisque le cavalier
attaquerait le fou donc il faut trouver
déjà un autre coup c'est pas évident
donc imaginons à 4,1 et là sur calais
des six échecs simplement sur trois des
quatre à bien y regarder on peut
simplement faire bouger un échec
et regardez ici c'est le pion qui bat le
pion et le fou qui empêche d'aller en c5
on peut pas aller en c4 toujours à cause
de ce cavalier on a on a toujours ce
petit mur on peut pas aller re 4 à cause
du cavalier et si on vient à 1,5 c'est
possible mais simplement fourrage deux
et on est obligé de revenir dans des 4
est donc là les noirs seraient
tranquilles
il demande pour les noirs c'est bien ici
dans cette position de faire de faire
nul donc si s'ils peuvent faire plus
facilement c'est tant mieux donc sur
cavaliers 1,8 simplement fou c'est un
mois ce qui explique que les blancs ne
joue pas calé au cap donc ce qu'elle ait
eu finalement est une tentative de
répéter la position
donc là on tente autre chose rare dit il
va très bien manoeuvré par la suite il
joue cavalli c7 alors déjà attention
pour les blancs puisque attaque le fou
et le pion donc il faut protéger les
deux mais simplement topalov shufu
détroit et qu'est ce qui se passe alors
on se dit sûr car et on essaye alors
regardez la manoeuvre c'est très simple
c'est une défense dynamique fous ces
quatre clouage et si les noirs protège
simplement trois ou quatre et c'est fini
le cavalier perdu il n'y a pas moyen de
le défendre le fou est sur la mauvaise
couleur on peut pas rajouter une pièce à
la défense ici donc il est simplement
perdu donc voilà c'est sûr on ne peut
pas apprendre ce pion 4 tout de suite
par contre donc les noirs jouent donc
une autre manoeuvre il joue simplement
fou décisive la grande parce que cavaler
bloqueurs par un foot locker 3 ou 4 pour
les blancs et la d5 voilà ça c'est pas
mal alors b5 protégé par le cavalier c7
c'est le plan d'aaland
donc ça c'est malin pourquoi il met les
pions à nantes sur la couleur opposée
donc ici socas blanche deux sont fous
voilà donc ce sont les pilons noires qui
font office de contrôle des cases
blanches voiliers et donc j'empêche je
crée une forteresse
j'empêche regardez ici c'est le roi noir
qui contrôle toutes ces cases jean pesce
une pénétration du roi blanc ne peut pas
venir aller chercher mes pions comme ça
facilement et les fous sont impuissants
a créé tout seul une rupture
donc en fait c'est une forteresse que
construit à tendance assez classique
aussi en finale
si vous avez un seul fou en général
c'est toujours mieux de mettre vos pions
sur la couleur opposée en général mais
il ya des exceptions mais en général sur
la couleur opposée à votre fou comme ça
ils jouent un rôle de complément
en termes de contrôle de cases donc il y
aura non seulement le cavalier qui peut
contrôler cases blanches mais maintenant
aussi des pions et après roi des 4 eh
bien on joue à six voilà maintenant on a
mis le pion à 6 à la défense du plan b 5
ce qui va libérer le calme nécessaire
puisque là sinon évidemment il ya
attention il ya le foot est roi qui
attaque et on pouvait pas jouer le
cavalier maintenant on va pouvoir bouger
ce cavalier le cas échéant si si si
l'occasion s'en fait sentir
il est libéré par le fait qu'on ait
défendu le pion des 5
on continue ou e2370 maintenant ça y est
j'ai réussi à ramener le roi vers le
centre où j'ai cinq échecs 3,17
il est bien centralisée l'europe on
n'est pas en éponge on n'est pas embêtés
très jolie plante à nantes pour réussir
à centraliser son roi et empêcher toute
pénétration du roi adverse fou des deux
fous g3 est la taupe à la va tenter un
gars une dernière chose mais qui ne
suffira pas il va tenter après j'ai cinq
ici est bien de créer un pion passé de
ce côté-là il a ainsi créé deux pions
passé ça va être très dur pour les noirs
de protéger les deux dates d'empêcher
les deux d'avancé
l'idée c'est de par exemple mettre un
fou en d3 et d'arrivée alors pour
l'instant c'est pas possible puisque le
foot j'ai tremblé d'arriver à jouer
ensuite h 4 h 5 et en faisant pression
maximale sur g6 ici pouvoir
force est la perte du pion h7 par
exemple le pion ici prendre 1 h 5
on va manger le pion à vii et après ceux
qui ont joué mais il peut aller à dame
est lent difficile d'empêcher à la fois
le plonger de la dame et le pion des et
ça risque d'être suffisant pour gober
une pièce et si on a à la bobine pièce
il reste environ encore ici on a deux
qui peut faire la différence qu'ils
seront obligés de faire sacrifier la
pièce manquante et avec deux fous on
peut mater aux échecs ça suffit donc
fausse deux échecs 3,5 fou j'ai trois
échecs 3,4 donc les blancs évite les
charges de fou puisque la l'avantagent
des blancs tiennent au fait qu'ils ont
la paire de fou faut pas oublier ça un
fou ce fait changer ce sera beaucoup
plus difficile puisqu'il y aura une
couleur de cases qui sera totalement
inattaquable donc là un an de continue
cavale de huit alors il va revenir à
nantes sur la fameuse case des six on
l'avait déjà vu un mec un échec et comme
on a vu ce roi n'a pas de case très
difficile pour lui donc ici alors après
j'ai 5 fu et f2 échec on veut ça une
fougue et trois échecs royal 4 cavaliers
8 donc fouillé cadre échec au roi
donc là ça c'est un coup simplement pour
demander où va le roi donc ici il vient
en 7 et x 6 x 6 l'idée des blancs
avaient ça y est c'est d'aller prendre
ce fameux prochaine dont on a parlé tout
à l'heure
alors attention quand même puisque si on
imagine surtout j'ai vite vous prend qui
pourrait y avoir un enfermement du fou
par roy et vii
et ensuite 3g 7 prend le foot on va
faire attention ce genre de menaces mais
en attendant c'est un honneur de jouer
de toute façon qu'à valider si c'est
cher voilà déjà voilà on remet le
cavalier on se rappelle qu on contrôle
les cases blanches et grises ce cavalier
et le fou lui il va pouvoir faire des
échecs sont casse doit donc le roi ben
il sait bien que si bien en d4 il va se
faire harceler par fou échec
donc au lieu de perdre du temps il va
directement en f3 puisque ton temps est
obligé d'y venir et la confort d'un
homme puisque hollande ici ne prend pas
le temps d'enlever son fou de la case d3
mais il joue tout de suite car les c4 il
dit bon écoute si tu prends mon fou par
exemple apprendre g3 simplement moi je
prends le pion t2 et on note que sur
fourrages set ça marche pas simplement à
cause de regarder ces magnifiques
croyais fuite puisque sur wafou prend il
ya roi g7 et le fou est perdu or vous le
dire il ya beaucoup de pions passé c'est
clair mais les noirs aussi en étions
passés ici qui peuvent s'avérer aussi
extrêmement gagnant et ils ont un
cavalier qui peut à la fois à contrôler
la casse des 6 et pourquoi pas venir
avec sept suez suffit et sera suffisant
pour aussi maintenir en respect ses
pions h3g 5 et ceux qui ont des 5 avec
l'aide du roi donc ce ne sera pas
suffisant
ça peut encore être nulle pour les
blancs mais c'est peut-être même être
les noirs qui peuvent gagner cette
partie après faire très attention à ça
ça pourrait quand même toute tentative
alors qu'havas les c4 en tout cas
propose un échange donc pousser un peu
pâlotte ne te rentre pas dans cette
variante est la food & 6 simplement on
revient sur sa fameuse case de blocage
on décide tranquillement et toujours pas
de fous j'ai vite en vue alors voyons
qu'est-ce qui se passerait sur fouquet 8
bien la même chose qu'on a vu puisqu'il
y aurait roi et fuite
prince est airois g7 et le fou est perdu
il faut laisser encore se sacrifier ici
mais le pion débloquer et on a des
pièces pour empêcher l'avancée de ses
pions donc le ca serait pas ça serait
pas bon
il faut des 6 3 4 à 5 c'est l'heure pour
un an
alors ça c'était le ce qu'on avait dit
en tout début de partie rappelez vous on
a deux pions passé ici contraint donc en
mettant en route ses pions a non
seulement on va pouvoir échanger soutien
qui peut être potentiellement dangereux
à long terme mais aussi créer de la
contrebasse et forcer les pièces
blanches a ajouté un deuil de ce côté là
maintenant et non plus de créer des
menaces tout seul de leur côté donc en
faisant ça ah non deux commencent à
équilibrer les menaces dynamiques de la
position envoyée qu'ont ils ont été
patients et noir pour consolider la
position et ne faire jouer leur petit
avantage de finale que au moment
opportun ici au 47e coup rouge et 4 x 3
regardez c'est l'heure que choisit un
nom aussi pour proposer ici on regarde
et non seulement un échange du fou c'est
un contre le x 3 mais aussi et là c'est
beaucoup plus dangereux des poussées à 4
b 4 b3 et je contrôle toutes les cases
pour venir jusqu'en bien donc ça très
dangereux faut quand même faire très
attention à la manoeuvre donc là topalov
nom commence à ne plus s'embarrasser de
détails
ils échangent et après cavale et prend à
trois on peut dire que quasiment le
boulot d'un an défini
parce qu'en fait
ce pion va très vite être échangés
contre un ou deux pions ici très vite
les blancs pour empêcher l'avancée de
ses pions mon devoir a mobilisé une
pièce le roi et les noirs dont se venger
sur le pion des cinq après quoi il
restera cavalli contrefout mais avec des
pions de même côté et symétrique alors
le full supérieur aux cavaliers s'il ya
des pions des deux côtés en l'occurrence
ici il y en aura plus que d'un côté
c'est le plan 2 nuls demande donc l'idée
c'est de simplifier cette dissymétrie et
donc de se ramener d'un seul côté et là
le fait que le cavalier une pièce à
courte portée ne sera plus un
désavantage
voilà on comprend à l'idée c'est que
quand on a un fou contre un cavalier si
vous avez des pions à gauche et des plus
haut à droite le fou peut jouer des deux
côtés un vous le mettez au bon endroit
il peut à la fois défendre d'un côté
attaque et de l'autre le cavalier lui
pour aller d'un côté à l'autre il va
jouer et de voir jouer un deux ou trois
coups pour passer d'un côté à l'autre à
chaque fois il va perdre du temps et ça
peut être un balancier qui est souvent
fatale mais si les pions sur le même
côté on peut pas jouer sur cette
différence donc 3,5 des blancs là l'idée
pour les barbes et de dire attention si
tu pousses trotter pions - je pousse sur
cases noires ici le fou contrôler les
caisses blanche dont on doive être
obligé de reculer
donc à nantes joue d'abord cavaliers
échec mal un échec et je contrôle la
case d'annoncé du pillon toujours un se
pressent pas à l'envoyer de pousser ses
pions pour des quatre rois des six
voilà maintenant c'est le roi qui
verrouille ici vous allez voir a pris
comme c'est limpide ce qui va suivre
après fouet deux car il ya trois
simplement évidemment le kabyle est
attaquée je protège mes 5 h théâtre il
tente encore des choses topalov liban
comme il se laisse jamais démonté échec
roi ces trois cavaliers des quatre
attaques le pion à 2 et le pion des 5
c'est fini après fou prend b5
car l epr en inde de regarder se trompe
pas on ne prend pas ce pion qui foutu de
toute façon le pion des 5
il est foutu puisqu'il ya déjà le roi
qu'est dessus le problème c'est ce plan
à 2,6 ce pion adresse ça peut être
un problème il fondera l'arrêté tôt ou
tard si les blancs arrive à choper le
pion à 5 ça peut être un vrai souci
surtout que les pions à ou h sont
extrêmement difficiles à arrêter par le
cavalier donc on se trompe pas de pions
on prend le bon cavale et prendra deux
échecs roi b3 et aprica va y avait
quatre c'est fini puis on est 500 fois
deux on va encore jouer quelques coups
qu'ils allaient prendre dès 5h cinq
taupes allofs simplifie simplement il
est il échange tous pourris calais prend
24 h 30 et 6 h 30 j'ai six simplement
fou c4 les blancs ont joué trois à
quatre fois f7 et se sacrifier après
avoir pris pion à 5
tranquillement il n'y a pas de problème
non plus ici pour les blancs dans cette
finale
voyez comme le fou est quand même fort
par rapport à un cavalier puisque même
avec une tour - on peut arriver à
simplifier très facilement il n'y a plus
assez de pions pour gagner la partie
voilà donc c'est quand même une très
belle finale avec des thèmes classiques
sur la grüne fait comme on l'a vu une
très belle défense donnant pas évidente
alors qu'on avait eu aurait peut-être pu
prendre un avantage dans la partie en
échangeant des cinq au lieu de la
manière qu'il a fait ça c'est dommage
peut-être pour lui mais topalov derrière
très très bien joué évidemment il a pris
cet avantage clair de la paire de fou
mais on en est très fort il a il a très
très bien joué cette finale
bien manoeuvrer son cavalier et c'est
fou pour bloquer la position qu'on l'a
vu bloquer les cases empêcher le roi
adverse de bouger et finalement
simplifiée toujours canton de cavalli
comprend le fou essayer d'éliminer les
plus éloignés et de se concentrer après
sûr sûr sûr les pions du même côté ça
permet d'équilibrer la force avec le fou
belle partie belle leçon à étudier à
pour tous les joueurs de greenfield et
pour les ceux qui veulent étudier les
finales c'est une belle leçon après
cette partie nulle les deux champions
sont à égalité au match égalité parfaite
2 victoires partout
il reste deux parties pour le titre de
champion du monde
donc je vous donne rendez vous pour les
parties suivantes évidemment étudié sur
diagonale tv et voir ce très beau
championnat du monde 2010 allende
topalov merci de nous avoir suivi sur
diagonale tv et à bientôt pour la suite
de ce championnat du monde
au revoir